NASA estimates that the value of all the minerals
in the asteroid belt exceeds this $600,000,000,000,000,000,000.
Or to put it in other words, roughly $100
billion for each person alive.
The fingerprints of koala bears are virtually
indistinguishable from those of humans.
In 1959 the United States Postal Service attempted
to deliver mail by cruise missile and successfully
shipped cargo from New Jersey to Florida in
22 minutes.
The "Yin-Yang" symbol was first used in Ancient
Rome, not China.
Your heart rate rises as much as 30% during
a yawn.
The first word spoken on the moon was Okay.
An apple will wake you up better in the morning
than coffee.
This is because of an apple's high sugar content.
If you keep a goldfish in the dark, it will
eventually turn white.
In nearly every species of mammal the female
lives longer than the male.
There is a service in Boulder, Colorado called
Hangover Helpers that will come to your place
the morning after a party.
Bring gatorade, cook everyone a breakfast
burrito and clean up for $20 per person.
Pope Francis, the leader of the Catholic Church
once worked as a bouncer in an Argentinean
bar.
John F Kennedy had his press secretary purchase
1,200 Cuban cigars and confirmed the purchase
was complete before signing the documents
that made the embargo against Cuba official.
Beetles taste like apples, wasps like pine
nuts and worms like fried bacon.
In Australia "Jedi" is an official religion,
known as Jediism, it has over 70,000 followers.
The word "dude" was first used in the late
1800s as an insult towards men who were overly
concerned with keeping up with the latest
fashions.
In ten minutes, a hurricane releases more
energy than all the world's nuclear weapons
combined.